[Music]
in a sense no one that knew us was like
surprised that we moved out here you
know everyone that knew was like yeah
that makes sense yeah we're both like
very environmentally focused you know
nature lovers
when i was growing up in toronto it was
like in an apartment we didn't have a
backyard i feel like i've just been
overwhelmingly surprised with like how
happy i am here
[Music]
last november simone weinstein and
celeste lopretto and their two dogs
chester and zara left their tiny
basement apartment in the city behind to
start a new life in the countryside
and they're not alone
a seismic shift is happening across the
country
as millennials look to put down roots
and start families
they're saying goodbye to canada's
biggest cities and settling in small
towns like this one
markdale ontario
population 1200
we're on a five acre
property
10 minutes outside of markdale we didn't
know too much about this area we
actually had never been to markdale we
just kind of fell in love with the
property but also fell in love with just
the area within weeks of ontario's first
lockdown house prices began to rise
celeste and simone saw their dream of
operating a small-scale farm in the
country slipping away
so they decided to take the leap we were
like if we wait any longer i don't know
if we'll be able to afford anything
anywhere near toronto or near guelph
which is where we were living at the
time i first thought it was a little too
good to be true i i was not expecting us
to be in such a beautiful home our end
goal was like farm but we didn't realize
that i guess it would it would be this
soon
celeste and simone run a vegan meal
delivery service called the conscious
kitchen here in markdale they've been
able to grow the garden they've always
wanted
[Music]
it's a quarter acre and then next year
we plan to basically fill it up with
mainly
summer crops like eggplant peppers
tomatoes and a lot of squash and melons
to do processing in our kitchen for the
business yeah she's got like the green
thumb she's a good farmer i just come in
and
kill tomato bugs
what did you think at first about
markdale i guess it looks quite similar
to you know most small towns you'll
drive through in ontario it's you know
one one stop sign one street light and
one strip of you know maybe 10 to 20
stores
but i think even since the year we've
been here it's changed like dramatically
[Music]
after years of decline markdale is
booming
the town now has not one but two street
lights
and a new supermarket and tim hortons
have arrived
businesses are opening on the downtown
strip and a new hospital is in the works
the elementary school which almost shut
down a few years ago due to low
enrollment is soon to be replaced with a
brand new facility
around every corner construction is
underway
multiple subdivisions are being built
by developers who say hundreds of homes
are being snapped up by young families
from southwestern ontario cities
this is one of the most significant
changes in migrant flows since the
industrial revolution it's signaling
the potential for a revitalization of
rural canada
michael hahn is a demographer who
studies internal migration until
recently small town canada particularly
destinations that are northern rural and
remote they were suffering quite
extensively
residents were rapidly aging and with no
young people moving to town many rural
areas faced population decline and labor
shortages
but now the pandemic has helped to
reverse the decades-old trend of young
people fleeing small towns in favor of
big cities the millennial generation are
at the age when people generally move
and settle down
and so after months of being trapped in
their apartments young people
seem to almost simultaneously reconsider
whether they wanted to live in a big
city like vancouver or montreal
add to that an affordability crisis that
has made buying a home in canadian
cities impossible for many young adults
and with some offices remaining closed
they're no longer tied to their desks or
their cities
so they're looking around for places to
live and one of the things that they're
increasingly considering is rural canada
rural destinations are no longer this
backwater
outdated outmoded
place to live anymore because the
amenities that previously were only
found in cities now exist there
that's largely due to the work of people
like akash desai the deputy mayor of
grey highlands the municipality that
mark dale is a part of he got into
politics at the age of 24 with the goal
of making the area more attractive to
people his age i was talking to a
student
who
was in grade 12 and she was graduating
and i said so you know what are you
going to do and she said well i'm going
to go off to university i said oh cool
so you'll move back and you'll you'll
settle down in markdown after and she
said why would i do that
so that's why i got involved i've heard
tales from a couple people that you know
there was a time not so long ago where
you know businesses were boarded up all
across the downtown and markdale was in
almost a dying state
so yes so that's that's correct and
one of the biggest issues we've had is
the lack of population really markdale's
population is going to see
a big rise of those new developments
what kind of impact do you think that
change is going to have on this little
town
i'm optimistic i think it's going to
make our make our town better it's going
to bring in people who think differently
who have
there will be more diversity of opinion
i think a lot of people share my
optimism
but for some markdale is changing too
much
global news spoke with several residents
who worried that their small town is
being taken over by people from the city
sometimes referred to disparagingly as
idiots
there are
locals that say you know are scared of
this change they say it's happening too
fast the town isn't ready
what message do you have for those
people i think the message that i can
send them is you know people that are
moving up they're people they share
similar aspirations similar goals they
want what's best for themselves their
family their kids
they're not really that different from
us change is never easy
but at the same time change is something
that
has to happen or else we risk stagnating
and then dying
you know so whatever issues there are
i'm sure we'll face them as a community
and we'll deal with them as a community
[Music]
we are walking country song we came we
got the dog we bought the pickup truck
we've got the land we watched the
sunsets off our back deck
it's really amazing
in early 2020 graham demarsh and ashley
patrick were house hunting from their
450 square foot condo in toronto
after searching two hours in every
direction they stumbled upon markdale
it really is a very cute town i really
gave us everything we needed but nothing
more if that makes sense and when we
were house hunting and looking it was
the first tim hortons we saw for a long
time and so we thought this is nice this
is new and we saw the food land was
being built so that was coming soon
across the street a hospital was being
built so we just felt a bit of a of a
revival of this what would have been
maybe a sleepier town and we thought
it feels exciting you can feel it in the
community and in the atmosphere ashley
and graham both still work from home for
toronto-based companies they're digital
nomads she's a travel agent and he's a
web developer
and while their jobs haven't changed
their lifestyle certainly has i'd
actually say i'm more outdoorsy than i
was before we got a pandemic puppy we
got a dog and so he's been a big
contributor of enjoying outdoor life
and being able to enjoy what's around us
and when they're not going for walks
with their dog hudson they're downtown
enjoying a sandwich at susan's deli
taking in the small pleasures of small
town life
[Music]
anytime you walk in to the deli
everybody is so welcoming they know you
by face by name you walk downtown you
run into people every time you go
downtown everyone's connected everyone
knows someone see you later
bye
yeah the community has just been
wonderful we really have just kind of
dug into the country life it's something
we we both
didn't expect to like as much as we do
we really were big city people and it
was it's a hard change but it's one that
we look back on and we're we're very
happy we made it
i think the only thing we miss is late
night food ubereats was definitely
definitely no food delivery out here
unfortunately yes you know it's it's
worth the trade-off i think
it might sound a little cheesy but i do
think it's been good for our soul to be
out here
these towns are
alive again
that's the good news the bad news is
that
it also with this rapid price
appreciation it pushes locals out of the
housing market potentially so what ended
up happening is that you almost had
these concentric circles of housing
price valuation it's almost as though
there was a drop of water and it just
rippled outward
[Music]
how are you nice to meet you
real estate agent and lifelong markdale
resident eric robertson showed us houses
in the area that have skyrocketed in
price so the place that we're going to
now
sold in april of 2021
for 570 000
and was purchased
in
2014
for 180 000
um so it's more than tripled in value in
that time frame
so this is it here the majority of our
buyers come from the south of here so
that can be there bee coming from
kitchener waterloo area mississauga
brampton toronto
a spike in demand also meant a spike in
property values
there's been a 40 increase in the past
year alone
eric says it used to take about four
months to sell a home in this area but
lately they're selling in 24 hours
this property is a two-year-old bungalow
just recently sold a few weeks ago for
nine hundred and three thousand dollars
so this property is directly across the
road from 400 acres of municipal forests
with trails we find the buyers coming to
our area are kind of looking for these
type of properties
lifelong locals sold this property to
cash in on the hot real estate market
but then had to move out of the area to
find something more affordable
it's a trend that's having major
repercussions for the largest employer
in town
chapman's ice cream
ashley chapman's parents started the
company
he's the vice president and oversees its
operations in markdale
it was uh
1973
my parents moved up to the middle of
nowhere and bought this
crappy little creamery that was in
really bad shape and
they spent over a year cleaning it
before they even started producing their
first
two liter package of ice cream
and uh that's how we started with my mom
my dad six employees and here we are now
markdale obviously has kind of been
booming since the pandemic began yes and
i wonder how that's impacting you how is
that impacting your business
it hasn't been particularly that great
for us um the expansion of markdale
essentially in the pandemic we've taken
like 10 years of growth
and and packed them into the last year
and a half a lot of our locals decided
you know what now's the time i'm going
to sell and i'm going to move out of the
area
so we've lost a lot of good employees
just by the the cost of housing
yeah i would have thought you know
more people coming
would be a good thing for you solve any
labor shortage that you might be facing
we have built our business off of
unskilled labor unlike a lot of places
definitely in manufacturing we do not
believe in part-time work
that does not exist at chapman's we we
provide full-time employment with
benefits
at very high wages but the people that
are coming up here are they're looking
for a good internet connection so
they're really not fulfilling
uh that unskilled labor role
everybody's favorite sandwiches
that's one of my favorite machines
[Music]
how bad is the labor shortage that
you're facing right now we're about 850
people if i could snap my fingers and
fix the problem i would be at a thousand
today but
guess what there's nowhere to live
there's nowhere to rent
we did have a labor shortage a small one
prior to the pandemic but
over the last year and a half it's
gotten
considerably worse
despite the challenges ahead for the
family business ashley says he's excited
to see new faces in markdale i was i was
born in this area
uh in 1979 and the
population sign of martel has never
changed
my entire life i was always wondering as
i grew up when is the day that they're
gonna go out there and
then we'll have a new population
so
we'll see that day might be soon
here's hoping
patricia ellingwood shares his
enthusiasm she's a transplant herself in
2002 she moved from halifax to markdale
i don't blame them for choosing my tail
i came here and i couldn't look back so
i can't i completely understand why they
would choose to make their home here too
it's just through a series of
unfortunate events
we
we had a lot of stress
brought on because of it
in may patricia and her ten-year-old
daughter were forced to leave the house
they had been renting for a decade when
the owner decided to sell
understandably the prices of real estate
had gone up and they were looking to get
out of the renting game and sell the
house so
we had to start looking for a new place
to live what was that process like house
hunting in markdale it was a nightmare
to find a place to live the biggest
barrier was the lack of availability the
increased rent didn't help i had you
know being here for 20 years had moved
previously and never had a problem
finding a place through some local
connections patricia found a new rental
in a town 30 minutes away
she says she's grateful to have it but
her cost of living have gone up
about 400 more a month just in rent and
then we have the increased cost of now
we're half an hour away so
twice a day we're driving that half an
hour drive so there's increased fuel
costs so
it does get fairly expensive what was
that entire you know ordeal like for you
and and your 10 year old daughter it was
very stressful on her she started to
break out in hives and have
more sensitivities to allergies and
things so
it's it's been a struggle it's been
tough but
we got through it
this small town revival isn't just
happening in markdale or even ontario
from coast to coast to coast rural towns
once far removed from the city next door
are being challenged and transformed
it's too soon to say whether this
migration will continue and for how long
but what's clear is that the pandemic
has made people rethink not only where
they want to live
but how they want to live
the pandemic really reminded people of
what's important and what's you know
perhaps what's not as important and one
of the things that's important is having
your own space being able to do the
things that you like definitely we would
like to like adopt children
at some point and that was kind of like
a big factor of us wanting to move out
here was i would really like to like
raise kids in a more rural environment
just more in in touch with nature
definitely more dogs that's in our
future
i think we have a lot ahead of us we'll
have to see kind of where that takes us
we'll have to see how we can contribute
to the community whatever that might
look like whether we you know might
consider breaking into the market and
opening a business here uh there is a
lot of potential and we often joke about
you know what else could mark dale
really need and how could we be a part
of that this is exactly where we want to
be